hey everyone my name is varsha dhata and
i'm a security and compliance specialist
with google cloud and today i would like
to talk to you about some of our newest
products
at google recapture enterprise
before we go into google's recaptcha
enterprise product let's talk a little
bit about what a captcha is and what it
does
a captcha is an acronym for completely
automated
public curing test to tell computers and
humans apart
it's a type of challenge response test
used in computing to determine whether a
user is a human or not
fairly straightforward right not really
there are a lot of nuances that go into
identifying a real user
versus a bot and recapture enterprise is
a complete solution
just built to do that and do this very
well
let's talk a little bit about some of
these evolving threats that we've seen
in the industry
users are constantly under attack from
credential stuffing
account takeovers and fraud all the time
and it's really unique compared to
protecting our own employees within the
company
because we have less control over the
environment that our users are in
but they are as important to our
business
we've seen that in 2018 alone there were
about 30 billion
attempted logins with stolen credentials
and 29
of those breaches involved those stolen
credentials
and an estimated eight percent of
revenue for
many online businesses is lost to fraud
every year
the problem is in the defense of these
systems especially when you go
all the way to the users uh computers
because it requires a lot of data
and ability to protect at the client
level in an environment that you do not
control
as you can imagine google has a lot of
experience in dealing with
fraudulent activities on our platform we
have over one billion users
each um across all of these nine
different products and we've
only learned on how to better protect
our users from frauds
from fraud over the last few years just
for some background here at google
we've been protecting our own systems
with two spectacular technologies over
the last decade
the first is recaptcha which defends
more than two million websites from
fraudulent bots
and the second one is a safe browsing
technology which defends over three
billion
devices from fishing in malware let's
take a look at these products in detail
some of the more common types of
fraudulent attacks we see
are account takeovers synthetic accounts
false
posts fraudulent transactions and money
laundering
recapture enterprise has built upon the
existing recapture platform that most of
us are familiar with
the goal of recapture enterprise is to
defend against these
various threats including but not
limited to scraping
fraud and account takeovers now we want
to make it very difficult for those
attackers to gain access
to your business to consumer services
and use them for malicious purposes
most importantly recapture enterprise
with recapture enterprise we can do this
while providing a frictionless
experience to your users and customers
the product acts as a barrier that is
placed for uh in front of your web
applications
where actions can be taken to stop bots
and fraudulent
activities from allah and and while
still allowing your users in
now let's take a look at the evolution
of google's recaptcha over the years
it got started with this quickly bit of
text that you're trying to read and
enter
and as god as bots got better um our
our defenses had to evolve and that's
why you see these click
boxes and crosswalks where the
challenges have become a little bit more
complex
and a lot of users actually have trouble
solving these and it's not the best user
experience either
um not only uh normally do we face
threats from ai but we also face threats
from farming
a large number of groups of people are
solving these challenges
for fraudsters um and now it comes down
to actually distinguishing the
transactions from fraudulent versus
non-problem transactions
and not just humans to bots the latest
version of free capture enterprise
is essentially a piece of javascript
that interacts with the user
um and gives you a risk score to
identify
whether the transaction or the user
interaction was alleged to make one or
not
so this means no text boxes and no
crosswalks
and just a snippet of javascript that
sits within your html pages
and there is no user interaction
required for the javascript to start
working
which means no friction from having to
actually solve the challenge
it's also based on the user's behavioral
analysis
on your website rather than relying on
just one form of challenge on your
webpage
so let's take a closer look at what's
included within recapture enterprise
now if you're familiar with recaptcha
weekly the enterprise version includes a
lot of
all of v3 and a lot more so it includes
an enhanced risk or
based mechanism which is based on
machine learning and is also
more specific to your website than just
generating bots
we also provide risk codes or reason
codes that allow you to better
understand
why we are detecting a certain behavior
as a as a bot or not now as a customer
you also have the ability to use the
annotation api to provide us feedback
whether or not a certain um as a certain
risk score that we provided was a false
positive versus a false negative
now remember that not all bots are good
or bad
it really comes down to understanding
your user behaviors and understanding
what your
business needs are now with recaptcha
enterprise we also have
mobile support with mobile sdks for
android and ios
we also have a new password leak
detection mechanism that's in early
access
we also have a two factor authentication
that can be implemented
for potential fraudsters um to further
assert their identity on your website
and finally since we are on the google
cloud platform
we provide sla and slo and also the
standard
gcp terms
now sensory camera enterprise actually
looks at the user behavior
and how they interact with the page and
synchronously in the background
the recaptcha servers formulate a risk
score based on the anomalies that we
have found on the website
now with the enterprise version we are
able to provide more granularity in
these risk scores that range between
zero to one
zero being a bad actor and one being a
good actor
now some bots actually have a bit of a
gray area that we need to provide
more details about and that's why the
enterprise
version actually provides your 10
pointer score where
which allows our customers to take more
precise decisions
on on their website and how they want to
apply
these protections on their website now
as an example you
almost always want to have a different
level of protection and security
around your high value pages like login
or check out
rather than a home page now let's take a
closer look at some of these
risk identifiers or reason codes we're
working on adding more and more of these
reason codes every day but here are a
few of them
now when a risk score is returned that
matches any behaviors
in the in this list and more we are
providing additional context
in the form of reason codes that can
assist you in tuning your responses to
your users and identifying
trends now let's do a high level
overview
of how all of these parts work together
um the page or the pages are actually
embedded with the recaptcha enterprise
now you can either have it on one single
page of your website or it could be
across all of your different pages on
the website the javascript will gather
the necessary data required to process
the risk score
and then that data is passed along as a
tokenized element
and encrypted um to the end user
now the predicted web application will
then receive that token when the user
actually interacts with the website
and then passes that token along over to
the recapture enterprise server
and then once the recapture enterprise
server is able to collect all of the
parameters and analyze it and provide a
risk score
it actually sends that risk or back to
your infrastructure
now based on the score you can actually
make a decision whether or not you want
to allow your user to continue
now the good news for current v3 users
is that the implementation is quite
similar
across recaptcha enterprise and
recaptcha v3 so if you're already a v3
user the transition is pretty much
just a line to point to a recapture
enterprise endpoint
so now that we have a risk or what kind
of action do we take
if a high risk score is returned it's
more likely that it's a real user
and there's you know you would want to
allow them to continue their journey on
your website
now if it's a low risk or depending on
the reason code you might want to take
either um a few types of actions you
might want to either reject that user
entirely and block them on your website
or you might want to provide a further
challenge like a two-factor
authentication to allow that user to
further assert their identity either way
you would want to
log all of these actions for further
analysis
now let's look at some success stories
around recapture enterprise
spotify was one of our earlier adopters
of recapture enterprise
we all know spotify and we love it they
were disruptors in the media industry
and transformed how we listen to music
some of the challenges that spotify was
facing included detection of bot traffic
and threats such as credentialed
stuffing
and abuse on spotify's website and apps
with recapture enterprise they were not
only able to effectively detect what
traffic but also protect and defend
against
threats coming from these bots another
one
another great example is empower
illinois empower
illinois is a statewide scholarship
granting organization that was created
in 2017 to serve children of illinois
through the state's tax credit
scholarship program
now some of the challenges that they
were facing was fraudulent application
submissions
and credential stuffing attacks by bots
with recapture enterprise they were able
to accurately detect bots
and also create a safe passage for
legitimate users and minimize the user
friction on their website
now let's take a look at webrisk api web
risk api is a google cloud service that
allows customer web applications to
check urls against
google's constantly updated list of
unsafe web resources
web risk api helps defend against
phishing links
malware links spam links amongst other
malicious urls
it acts as a barrier between fraudsters
and customer website applications
protecting them from malicious urls
being posted on their website
let's take a closer look at weber's kbi
we all know that urls contain unsafe
elements like phishing
malware and unwanted software and it's
often impossible to find this before our
users do
that's why we have webrisk api a new
offering from gcp that enables any
company to find
unsafe urls on their website now
wordpress includes
data on more than a million unsafe urls
and
users and uses google's safe browsing
technology to defend against malicious
urls
now let's take a look at how webrisk api
actually works
assume that attackers are trying to
exploit
the acme reviews by posting unsafe links
onto an even submission feature page
to defend their users and their site
against these
kind of attacks acme decides to use the
webrisk api to filter all
incoming posts for unsafe content
acme needs to essentially extract those
urls from the posts
and send them to webrisk api where
um and a web risk api will be able to
identify whether a url is unsafe or not
now depending on the decision that
webrisk api makes
acme can then decide to either post or
not post those urls on their website
now let's look into some of these thread
categories
webps kpi also provides information on
why a certain url was deemed malicious
based on some of the mentioned thread
types on the screen here
now this allows customers to take a more
educated decision
on whether or not to block these
malicious urls
now here's a remediation response for
example let's look at let's take a look
at the
sample workflow for weber's kpi once the
api returns the result if the url is not
a malicious one
our customers can choose to allow the
link to be then utilized on their
website
but if the url is malicious their
customer
then the customer can either decide to
block the
access to the website entirely by using
something like a web proxy
or flag the post as a malicious post or
even block the post entirely from being
submitted on the website
either way logging these activities is
always a good practice to allow scope
for future
analysis now that you've heard all the
awesomeness about recapture enterprise
and web risk api it's time to take
action
if you're facing any issues regarding
your fraudulent activities on the
website
we can help you with it please reach out
at
cloud.google.com recaptcha enterprise
and cloud.google.com
webrisk and get in touch with our sales
and technical teams
um to help protect your website
thank you for tuning in today